jean clément et françois duchesne ont
perdu la vie dans les événements
tragiques survenus à québec dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche ces événements
remettre dans lumière la question de
l'accès aux soins en santé mentale au
québec
même le maire régis labeaume souhaite un
débat national
aujourd'hui québec a devancé un
investissement de 100 millions de
dollars en argent neuf à être investis
d'ici 2022
on sent donc l'urgence d'agir comment
favoriser rapidement d'accès et le suivi
la prise en charge de personnes qui ont
un problème sérieux de santé mentale
mon premier invité sur ce sujet ce soir
et lionel carmant ministre délégué à la
santé et aux services sociaux du québec
bonsoir monsieur le ministre mais menés
24 60
je vous connais monsieur bonsoir sommes
de tout coeur avec le peuple autrichien
ce soir également oui celle de la
violence de la violence de la violence
vous avez fait une annonce importante
aujourd'hui qui était réclamé que
généralement bien accueilli cela dit
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
les faits réels de ces mesures annoncées
cet argent investi en 2022 comme à lille
famille l'épreuve de quelqu'un qui
souffre de santé mentale peut avoir la
certitude que cette personne aura les
soins nécessaires
écoutez le premier le premier
investissement c'est pour le l'accès aux
services psychologiques qui sont décriés
par par tout le monde
les délais excessifs que l'on rencontre
on a fait une grande amélioration dans
les délais d'attentes mais je crois que
pour faire plus il fallait qu'on utilise
l'accident aux services privés et
l'ordre des psychologues nous a offert
sept mille heures par semaine et deux
psychologues qui vont venir nous aider à
réduire cette liste d'attentes
c'est avant tout dans cette miller
semaine ah ouais ce qu'on voulait
démontre qu'on veut démontrer également
notre approche en est une
d'interdisciplinarité alors oui on veut
utiliser les services de psychologues
on veut utiliser les services de tous
les intervenants de première ligne qui
peuvent nous donner un coup de main en
santé mentale pour effectivement
diminuer la liste datant d'avant le
tableau si vous voulez
et monsieur le ministre on va le
décliner pour le public dans le 35
millions à l'achat de services dont
c'est sous ce chapeau donc vont
s'inscrire les soins en psychologique
était réclamée selon des psychologues 20
que ce soit universel mais là c'est un
début heureusement des services équipe
sentinelle on pourrait en parler donc de
la compagne en tête des services
policiers organismes communautaires un
investissement et dans prévention 5
millions de dollars notamment pour cette
fameuse ligne d'appel
le maire la bombe visait aujourd'hui on
ne peut faire l'économie d'un débat et
s'interrogeaient sur des questions
fondamentales
est ce qu'au delà de ces 100 millions
vous comptez faire ce débat national sur
la santé mentale qui était on le dit
beaucoup depuis des années le moi je
suis dans cette émission je l'aï dit la
semaine dernière encore avec le dr
arruda a le parent pauvre de la santé
passée comme invisible à sainte angèle à
la santé mentale sauf qatari des drames
tout à fait ça représente quand même le
tiers des consultations les
investissements étaient insuffisants et
encontre corriger la chose
maintenant on a fait deux forums en 2019
pour amorcer ce débat là et malgré sa
crise stoppée par la pandémie on
s'attendait à des visites propres à
travers le québec pour rencontrer les
groupes de passants des groupes de
familles maintenant avec les députés de
l'opposition dans une démarche non
partisane
on va continuer ce débat en travaillant
avec les violences communautaires en
travaillant avec les professionnels pour
déployer le prochain plan d'action
interministériel en santé mentale
il ya plein problèmes réels que je m'en
entretenir tout à l'heure avec deux
psychiatres qui travaille notamment
beaucoup auprès des jeunes et des avec
des équipes multidisciplinaires
mais ce qui semble ressortir au niveau
des difficultés c'est la fameuse pénurie
de personnel la pénurie de travailleurs
sociaux d'ergothérapeutes on les invente
pas ces gens là il faut les trouver mais
je dois vous dire que depuis dois vous
dire que depuis notre annonce du 6 mai
le premier 31 millions qu'on a injecté
pour le pour la queue vide et le plan
d'action santé mentale dans le contexte
de vide
on a quand même recruté trop
à 120 intervenants donc c'est
significatif si on en recrute chaque
mois les intervenants additionnel donc
on croit que le 250 qu'on veut comme
annoncé la semaine dernière pour la
clientèle jeunesse et les sentinelles
qu'on a annoncé aujourd'hui on va être
capable de les recruter
et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on
demande aux psychologues du secteur
privé de nous donner un peu de temps
pour nous aider à vider les listes
d'attentes dans le secteur public vous
êtes d'accord avec moi
la semaine dernière soit vous vous
réjouissiez que 16 mai personne
maintenant seulement sur les attendent
les 16000 personnes qui pouvaient
attendre enfin les délais d'attentes ce
qu'on a fait ici là le temps d'attentes
pour être entre 6 et 24 mois de la
détresse cependant de 6 à 24 mois avant
d'avoir du service est inacceptable et
intolérable
d'accord avec vous mais quand on est
arrivé on a vu 28000 sur la liste
d'attenté
ouais et encore une fois on essaie de
changer la proche
au québec 70 % des gens sont vus par des
psychologues et des psychiatres
nous on veut inverser cette tendance là
que la première ligne contribue plus à
la prise en charge des problèmes de
santé mentale
j'ai eu les témoignages de médecins de
famille qui se sentent diminue dans leur
clinique parce qu'ils ont pas ce qu'il
faut pour référer peut-être que ça votre
investissement va corriger les choses
oui absolument on veut faciliter l'accès
à ce fameux guichet d'accès en santé
mentale
on veut le connecter avec la plateforme
pour l'heure rejoint les psy car on veut
le connecter avec tous les services
disponibles pour ce soit vraiment un
outil utile et rapide pour diriger les
patients vers le bon service au bon
moment deux questions rapidement pour
vous monsieur clairement pas ce que je
vais les aborder avec mes des
psychiatres tout à l'heure certains
demandent depuis des années des
amendements de la loi sur la protection
de malade mental qui implique un secret
médical pour les proches qui implique le
refus de traitement on peut bien ternes
et quelqu'un pour de 36 72 heures mais
la personne a le droit de refuser un
traitement et celle refusons la rumeur
en liberté parce qu'on est une société
qui reconnaît les droits et libertés de
la personne
êtes vous prêt à réfléchir sur des
amendements législatifs
même le maire labeaume poser la question
aujourd'hui j'en ai parlé avec le
président de l'association des médecins
psychiatres du québec
c'est une chose que qu'il faut continuer
à discuter on parle de projets de
services plus plus en communauté qui
pourrait également aider mais oui je
suis ouvert à en discuter avec les
psychiatres et surtout aussi il faut
penser au groupe au groupe de parents ou
aux familles de ces gens là aux groupes
communautaires qui ont également leur
mot à dire
souvent les parents sont dépassés épuisé
non aucune information veulent aider un
proche qui saute de santé mentale et
puis à cause du secret médical qui
feraient ils ont pas accès peuvent pas
aider puis souvent les drames
surviennent était trop tard on a entendu
beaucoup de thé voyageant sans cela tout
à fait plus on doit travailler aussi à
déstigmatiser la maladie mentale
ça aussi c'est quelque chose que je que
je veux faire et que je travaille avec
tout
avec toutes les instances pour réussir à
perse à mieux les intégrer dans la
société a beaucoup de travail à faire
effectivement bien sûr aujourd'hui mon
collègue david celli rapporte que
plusieurs agressions du personnel
notamment cité la santé laval encore un
incident grave le 25 octobre albert
prévost l'été dernier un médecin avait
été poignardé le personnel dédié à la
santé mentale dans les centres
hospitaliers sont dépassés sont vivre
dans l'inquiétude les juges envoie les
patients la mêlée dhuizon parce qu'il
faut pour se protéger afin de vous faire
quelque chose
oui bon on en veut investir aussi dans
les ressources plus spécialisés surtout
au niveau de l'institut pinel
mais je pense qu'il faut regarder aussi
pour aider tout le monde tant dans tous
les centres
allez tous les différents centres
hospitaliers ya des gains mardi la
psychiatrie parce que on tient notre
propre personnel il faut pour mieux les
protéger effectivement au mieux les
outils aussi france pour parler de la
formation continue aussi d'améliorer les
pratiques à travers le québec
très bien monsieur le ministre on merci
beaucoup au revoir merci à vous pour
voir